Spidey will be dropping in on Iron Man a
co this weekend and Captain America
Civil War but why is it taken the
wall-crawler so long to meet up with his
marble mates I'm Simon and this is your
web slinging news update since sonia
marble partner to bring spider-man to
the comic book company Cinematic
Universe it's not been known which
studio would have creative control over
spider-man's next movie spider-man
homecoming in an interview with hey you
guys Marvel Studios President Kevin
foggy talked about his company's
relationship with Sony and how the
upcoming movie is coming along revealing
that Marvel is calling the creative
shots on homecoming well I've known all
those people at Sony for a very long
time Amy Pascal Tom Rathman who run Sony
now I've known for years so it's been
great they really are supportive in
allowing us to make the creative
decisions to make the movie but they've
been great partners so far so good on
that movie fire also talked about how
robert downey jr. red with spider-man
actor tom holland during his audition
saying that it was seeing Tom and Robert
together which made them realize tom was
by far the best choice you can expect to
see Robert Downey jr. as Iron Man in
spider-man homecoming are you glad that
Spidey is back in the hands of his
creators or maybe you miss McQuire and
his evil emo spider-man let me know in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter i'm at the jagan or thanks for
watching and for your entertainment news
keep it gamespot